after 16 days of non-stop negotiations
on a possible nuclear deal with Iran US
Secretary of State John Kerry was
hopeful that a solution could soon be
reached but he said difficult questions
still had to be answered including to
what extent inspectors would have access
to Iran's military sites and how quickly
economic and financial sanctions would
be lifted the West has long suspected
Iran of using its nuclear research
program for military purposes that's an
accusation Tehran vehemently denies it
insists that has the right to use
nuclear power to generate electricity
the new deal stipulates that Iran freeze
its research program in response
economic sanctions which have crippled
the country in recent decades would be
loosened even if a deal is reached in
Vienna there's no certainty it would be
ratified israel says it will call on the
u.s. to block the proposals and US
president barack obama must win approval
from congress before any deal goes
through high-ranking republicans in
washington are already saying they'll
vote no it would be the most significant
improvement in relations between the
west and Iran since the Islamic
Revolution in 1979 that something Obama
will be keen to achieve as his term as
US president draws to a close 1201